soixante jeunes pour chanter le voyage
de martin un groupe qui les accompagnent
un chef de choeur et c'est du sérieux
on est en train de travailler leur jeu
nous intéresse pas on a cinq concerts à
faire c'est le plus important
quand c'est marqué plus a dit mais vous
savez qu'on sorte de tempo n'ayez pas
donné de trois quarts qui ne regarde pas
à l'origine la pièce est une commande de
la ville de tours pour le mil 700e
anniversaire de saint martin une
composition originale de jean christophe
cholet jazzy et polyglotte il aura fallu
un an et demi de répétition pour les
jeunes chanteurs de la maîtrise
d'enfants et le choeur de jeunes du
conservatoire de tours où travaillent
séparément et un choeur de jeunes à
maîtriser leur propre adore et donc on
travaille comme ça et après parfois on
fait des répétitions avec monde avec les
instruments parce qu'avant fédérer sans
les instruments qui vont avec ifs
après le concert de novembre à l'église
saint-julien après le concert de ce
lundi soir à la mairie
les jeunes vont partir en tournée
européenne cinq dates dans les pas du
patron de la ville de tours et cinq
oeuvres retracent les gros moment et
nous sommes à faire donc c'est justement
essayer de refaire son chemin on se sera
plus rapide mais oui donc on va aller en
république tchèque en allemagne avant
ensuite en italie puis en suisse et à
prendre en france
au total 3500 kilomètres en bus à
travers l'europe pour un budget qui
avoisine les 35 mille euros et pour
financer le tout une cagnotte a été
ouverte sur internet que le coût du car
ces seize mille euros plus de 16000
euros après il ya des frais annexes
le payer les hôtels pour les chauffeurs
à certains endroits on oblige aussi
payer les hébergements pour les enfants
les nourrir etc
donc c'est un très gros budget
[Musique]
e
et donc on a monté une cette cagnotte
sur hello aso pour nous aider à financer
car et c'est vrai que ça monte pas
beaucoup alors je suis un peu déçu parce
que je pensais qu'un tel projet
d'envergure allait quand même donner
envie aux gens de participer
l'aventuré européenne et chorale est à
suivre sur le facebook de la maîtrise
d'enfants du conservatoire de tours le
plus court chemin aussi pour faire un
don salvateur